ANYHOW, WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
TIME TO WASTE SO HERE'S YOUR
RACIST STUFF FOR TONIGHT.
>> THE NATIONAL CHAPTER OF SIGMA
ALPHA EPSILON SHUTTING THEIR
UNIVERSITY OF OKLAHOMA CHAPTER
AFTER THIS SHOCKING VIDEO
SURFACED APPEARING TO SHOW
MEMBERS USING A RACIST CHANT.
>> Larry: RACISM DOESN'T EXIST
ANYMORE, LARRY.
( LAUGHTER )
WHY DO YOU ALWAYS HAVE TO FOCUS
ON RACE ON YOUR SHOW?
JUST STOP.
( LAUGHTER )
YOU FIRST.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
WHAT WAS I SUPPOSED TO DO?
SERIOUSLY, RIGHT?
I'LL STOP TALKING ABOUT RACE
WHEN PEOPLE STOP BEING RACIST.
AND QUICK NOTE TO PEOPLE
CAPTURING RACISM ON THEIR
PHONES, COULD YOU PLEASE STOP
SHOOTING VERTICAL VIDEOS?
HAVE YOU NEVER HEARD OF ASPECT
RATIO WIDE SCREEN?
I WANT TO EXPERIENCE MY HATE IN
16:9 NOT 2:5, ALL RIGHT.
JUST SAYING.
I GOTTA GIVE CREDIT WHERE THE
CREDIT IS DUE.
THE UNIVERSITY OF OKLAHOMA TOOK
SWIFT ACTION.
>> THE UNIVERSITY OF OKLAHOMA
PRESIDENT DAVID BOREN HAS
EXPELLED TWO STUDENTS RELATED TO
THE RACIST CHANT INCIDENT.
>> Larry: THAT'S RIGHT, THEY
ALSO KICKED THE FRATERNITY OFF
CAMPUS.
SO DON'T WORRY, YOU WON'T BE
SEEING ANY MORE OF THOSE FRAT
BOYS UNTIL THEY'RE YOUR
CONGRESSMAN.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
RIGHT.
WELCOME TO AMERICA, EVERYBODY.
THAT'S HOW IT WORKS.
( LAUGHTER )
WHO'S SUPERVISING THESE FRAT
BRATS, ANYWAY?
I MEAN, WASN'T THERE AN ADULT
PRESENT?
>> OVERNIGHT ANOTHER VIDEO HAS
SURFACED.
THIS ONE APPEARS TO SHOW THE
FRATERNITY'S 78-YEAR-OLD HOUSE
MOTHER.
>> Larry: OH, THAT'S GOOD.
A HOUSE MOTHER.
FINALLY, THE VOICE OF GENTLE
REASON, OH!
WHAT IS THIS? WHAT DOES LITTLE
ANGEL HAVE TO SAY?
>> Larry: MAN, OKLAHOMA!
WHAT THE ( BLEEP ) IS GOING ON
THERE?
SERIOUSLY!
SHAME ON YOU, LADY.
YOU'RE A FRAT HOUSE MOTHER.
YOU SHOULD KNOW BETTER.
YOU HAVE NO EXCUSE.
>> IN A WRITTEN STATEMENT,
GILBOW SAYS SHE IS HEARTBROKEN
BY ANY RACIST PORTRAYAL.
SHE DOES NOT TOLERATE ANY FORM
OF DISCRIMINATION AND SHE WAS
ONLY SINGING ALONG TO A RAP
SONG.
>> Larry: OH, OH, REALLY,
RACIST GRANDMA.
THAT'S A SONG?
WELL, WHAT SONG IS THAT?
♪ DON'T BELIEVE ME ( BLEEP )
DON'T BELIEVE ME JUST WATCH ♪♪
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
>> Larry: SORRY, FRAT MA, MY
BAD.
I GUESS YOU CAN SING IT, BUT
MAYBE NOT WITH SO MUCH GLEE.
ANYHOW, TO HELP GIVE SMUS MORE
PERSPECTIVE ON THE S.A.E.
FRATERNITY CULTURE, 1990s
OKLAHOMA FRAT GUY, D-TRAIN.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
THANKS FOR JOINING US, D-TRAIN.
>> LARRY, PLEASE, DON'T CALL ME
D-TRAIN ANYMORE.
I'M AN ADULT.
I WORK ON WALL STREET.
CALL ME DENNIS.
>> Larry: ALL RIGHT.
>> DEEP DICK DENNIS. BOOM!
WHASSUP, BRO?
>> Larry: I THINK I'LL JUST GO
WITH DENNIS.
>> DEALER'S CHOICE, BRO,
DEALER'S CHOICE
>> Larry: I'M ASSUMING YOU SAW
THE VIDEO OF YOUR SAE BROTHERS.
>> I DID, IT WAS DISGUSTING.
I COMPLETELY DENOUNCE IT.
YOU CANNOT USE THAT WORD.
>> Larry: GOOD, YOU TOTALLY
AGREE.
I'M WITH YOU.
>> I COULDN'T AGREE MORE, THAT
WORD IS RACIST AND OFFENSIVE.
CLEARLY THE SONG SHOULD HAVE
BEEN.
♪ THERE BE NEVER BE A BLACK GUY
IN S.A.E.
THERE WILL NEVER BE A BLACK GUY
>> Larry: WAIT, WAIT, WAIT,
HOLD ON.
I DON'T THINK YOU SEE THE POINT.
>> OH, GOD, I'M SO SORRY.
WHAT DO YOU GUYS GO BY NOW,
AFRICAN AMERICAN?
I GOT IT
>> LET ME TRY THAT ON FOR SIZE.
♪ THERE WILL NEVER BE AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN AT S.A.E.
♪ ♪.
>> Larry: STOP IT!
>> YOU'RE TOTALLY RIGHT, THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN THING DOES NOT
WORK.
IT TOTALLY SCREWS UP THE RHYTHM.
NOT THAT I HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT
>> Larry: LOOK, THE ISSUE HERE
IS NOT THE SPECIFIC WORD.
IT'S THE SENTIMENT THAT YOU'RE
EXCLUDING MINORITIES.
>> DUDE.
DUDE.
( LAUGHTER )
MAYBE YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT
A FRAT IS, DUDE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT EXCLUDING
ANYBODY.
IT'S ABOUT INCLUDING PEOPLE WHO
ARE EXACTLY LIKE YOU.
( LAUGHTER )
>> Larry: THAT REALLY DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE.
>> BECAUSE YOU'VE NEVER
EXPERIENCED THE BONDING WITH
YOUR BROS, BRO.
LARRY, UNTIL YOU GET ALL YOUR
FRIENDS TOGETHER ON A CHILLY
EASTER SUNDAY AND RUN ACROSS A
FOOTBALL FIELD FOR SIX HOURS
WITH YOUR THUMB UP EACH OTHERS'
ASSES YOU'LL NEVER REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT BROTHERHOOD IS
ABOUT.
>> Larry: I HAVE TWO BROTHERS
AND I'M A BROTHER.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
I UNDERSTAND BROTHERHOOD.
>> WHATEVER, DUDE, WHATEVER,
DUDE.
>> Larry: D-TRAIN, EVERYBODY.